[MUSIC PLAYING]
JS RAFAELI: We're here
to talk about drugs.
But I'm just going to start
with a little kind of quiz.
Who here in the
context of drugs has
heard of a thing called
the British System?
Like, capital B capital S,
British System, formal thing.
For viewers, at home
that's zero people.
[LAUGHTER]
And you guys are Google.
I mean, you have
access to information.
But don't feel too bad,
because we've done--
I've asked the same question
at criminology departments
in major universities
with people
who specialize in drugs policy.
And the results weren't
actually that much better.
It's a really interesting thing.
So we started researching--
I mean, we were researching
drug policy for a long time
together for another book.
And we started researching
the history of it.
And what we uncovered was
this really fascinating kind
of lost thread of
British history.
And we found it very
revealing, not just
about drugs and the
way they're governed,
but about the intellectual
and political traditions
of this country and about how,
like by reflection, the nature
of global drugs policy and how
it works, and more importantly,
how it doesn't work.
So we're conscious of time.
Give you a very quick,
like, potted history
of how drug policy developed,
particularly in Britain.
From the 19th century, the drugs
that we consider illegal today
were basically actually legal.
You could buy them in
apothecaries, corner stores.
People brewed poppy
head tea as a sort
of folk remedy, painkiller, in
the absence of, like, a health
system.
And aspirin hadn't
been invented yet.
As the 19th century
ends, there's
the emergence of a professional
class, a new professional class
of a pharmacist.
This had never
been heard before.
Immediately what breaks out is
a sort of turf war between two
also newly emerging sets
of professional classes.
You have medical
health professionals,
which has been a newly
professionalized industry,
and you have civil servants
and a newly emerging
professional bureaucracy.
There's this little
tussle between the two.
And this happens all over
the sort of developed world
as to who is going to control
the supply of medicines,
but also these illicit
drugs, like opium.
Cannabis eventually became
part of that conversation,
and cocaine when
it was invented.
All three of which Queen
Victoria was quite partial to,
incidentally.
So this tussle sort of
goes on over the end
of the 19th century
as science advances.
And then World War I happens.
Post-World War I, the first
British Ministry of Health
is formed in 1919.
And they figure, right, we
need to figure this stuff out.
Drugs are actually
becoming an issue
on the international scene,
particularly from the US, which
we'll talk about in a minute.
We need to figure this out.
So they formed a committee
called the Rolleston committee.
The Rolleston committee
meets and they basically
figure out a system which became
known as the British System.
And what the British System
entailed in its most basic
iteration was that if
you are a heroin addict--
and it was specifically
largely about heroin,
which is the most
addictive drug--
if you were addicted to heroin,
you can go to your doctor
and say, listen,
I'm a heroin addict.
And with no judgment, they'll
say, OK, that's unfortunate.
But we'll supply your heroin.
We will give you
heroin-- not methadone,
none of these other substitutes.
We will supply you
heroin from your doctor.
You don't need to
go to a gangster.
You don't need to go
to a black market.
We'll give it to you.
And what's very
interesting about--
that might be quite
shocking that this
happened sort of in living
memory in this country.
You go to your doctor
and they give you
drugs which we consider
evil or illegal.
What's very interesting about
the way the Rolleston committee
and the British
System as it emerged
is the language that was used.
There was no moralizing.
There was no sense
that drugs were evil
or that taking drugs or
being addicted to drugs
was a moral failing.
We sort of refer to it as
like these unfortunate people
who are addicted to drugs.
It was an accident.
And this system was instituted.
And it worked for decades.
What's interesting is that there
was another system emerging
across the Atlantic
in the United States,
a different way of
dealing with drugs, which
was intensely
moralizing, where drugs
were considered a moral evil.
And the only way with
which to handle them
was not through the
medical profession,
as it was under
the British system,
but by law
enforcement, which is--
one can read many
things into that
about American approaches
between the individual
and the state and the
Sheriff with the badge
and a gun and all this stuff.
But another time.
So the American way of
dealing with these drugs
was, A, moralizing,
and B, super racist.
Like, it was rooted absolutely
in racism, particularly
in its real origins in
anti-Chinese racism.
Hundreds of thousands
of Chinese workers
have been brought to the United
States to build the railroads.
As soon as the
railroads were finished,
the establishment and
white America, suddenly
had to figure out, right,
there are thousands-- hundreds
of thousands of now
unemployed Chinese people.
And it became a
problem for them.
And attacking
opium, the practice
of taking opium, which had been
largely forced on the Chinese
by the British--
again, another
story-- became a way
to attack Chinese
communities and to limit
Chinese immigration.
And there's some really--
like, these quotes started
flooding out from newspapers.
This is a newspaper from San
Francisco describing opium dens
where white women
and Chinamen sit side
by side under the effects
of this drug, a humiliating
sight to anyone with
anything left of manhood.
And just stuff that you
hear today and you go, yeah.
The campaigner
Richard Hobson, he
was a major guy in the US
incipient war on drugs--
"Like the invasions
and plagues of history,
the scourge of narcotic drug
addiction came out of Asia."
Again, you hear that
today and it's just
profoundly disgusting.
But this was the tenor
of language at the time.
Opium and eventually heroin
was particularly associated
with the Chinese community.
Cocaine-- they replicated
it with cocaine
in African Americans.
There's quotes in the book
which I will not read now
which are profoundly disturbing.
And marijuana with Mexicans
and Hispanic Latin Americans--
community.
It was a process which was
repeated again and again
to attach a certain drug to
a certain ethnic community
and use that to make the drug
illegal as a way of attacking
minorities.
This resulted in this sort of
early version of what we now
call the war on drugs and
the American way of making
all drugs illegal, which is--
that idea didn't
exist here, as I said.
We had the British
System over here.
In the States, they
made everything illegal.
Now, which system works better?
If your aim is to control
drug use, we can--
and limit drug use and limit
the dangers of drug use--
we can look to the numbers.
The exact numbers for,
let's say, the '40s and '50s
in America are
sort of unknowable.
But it's in the mid to high
hundreds of thousands--
NEIL WOODS: Low to mid
hundreds of thousands.
JS RAFAELI: Several hundred
thousand heroin addicts
in the United States in
the mid-40s, early-50s.
In the United Kingdom--
I'll read you a
quote from the book.
"In 1959, there were 62 known
heroin addicts in the UK.
By 1964, this had risen to 342."
Now, this five year rise
from 62 to 342 heroin addicts
here was considered
a crisis here.
It was like, oh my
God, we have 350 heroin
addicts in the entire country.
You can compare the numbers.
I mean, I remember going over
these statistics and thinking,
there was a time in living
memory when the entire heroin
addict population of the UK
would be a bit of a squeeze
but it could fit in this room.
That's in living memory, 1964.
It's not that long ago.
The Beatles' first LP had only
come out two years earlier.
So in terms of the effectiveness
of controlling addict numbers,
we see the British System
actually was actually
much more effective.
There are very technical
reasons for that, which I'd
like to get into in a minute.
But I'm going to let Neil
get on in one second,
because I just want to
keep it clipping along.
Why did the British
System get shut down?
Essentially, I mean,
the short answer
is American what we call
cultural imperialism.
The Second World War happens.
Every single developed economy
ends the Second World War
poorer except one,
the United States.
The United States
ended the war richer.
There are these
very shocking quotes
we found where in
the aftermath of war,
as the incipient organization
that grew into the United
Nations comes about, the
American organization which
became the FBI, the predecessor
to the FBI, goes [INAUDIBLE],,
you want that military aid?
Make drugs illegal.
You want our political
and diplomatic support?
Make drugs illegal.
And what we now as the war
on drugs was forced on the--
through the United
Nations was forced
on an unwilling
rest of the world
by United States
diplomatic, military,
and economic pressure.
The major holdout, the
major developed economy
that resisted that,
was the United Kingdom.
It's a surprise-- we think
of Anglo-American relations
and we think of the UK
following the US's lead a lot.
It's a cliche.
In fact, it's interestingly,
in this particular field
of policy, Britain was
a resistor to that,
and led a really kind of
noble diplomatic resistance.
But I'm going to let Neil
jump in to tell you how this--
Neil has experienced the
results of this on the streets.
And I'll let him take over and
tell you about his experience.
NEIL WOODS: Well,
I mean, I grew up
seeing the drug war as a war.
So when I went into
the police, I was--
I understood it, I
thought, quite clearly.
And as JS says, there was only
a few hundred problematic heroin
users in the UK in the 1960s.
That went up to 350,000
by the end of the 1980s.
So there's a very clear
cause and effect there.
But of course, that
cause and effect,
that's what brought
me into the drug war.
As a young police officer,
I've got an attachment
to the drug squad because of
the moral panic about crack
and heroin on our streets.
And I got roped into
working undercover.
And it was just beginning.
It's this type of
undercover work just begun
at that time in 1993 in the UK.
And the first time I
worked undercover, I
was sent to a door
with a 20 pound
note to buy some crack cocaine.
And the guy-- this huge,
scary guy, I thought--
but then when he
sold me the crack,
he said, now you take care now.
Don't get arrested.
He was quite considerate
to me, really.
And so I went back
to the drug squad
with my 20 pound stone of crack
cocaine, said, I've got it.
But then that defined the
next 14 years of my life.
And that's the work I then
did for the most part--
for the biggest proportion
of that time for 14 years.
Now, I say it was
easy the first time
and he was quite considerate.
But of course, drug
dealers get sent to prison.
And they speak to
other drug dealers.
So quite quickly
they knew that there
was a new tactic out there.
And so the next people
were more suspicious.
And it was more
difficult. So I realized
that I had to spend time
manipulating people.
I also worked out that the
easiest people to manipulate
are the most vulnerable.
It's true.
It's a basic-- it's a
truism of undercover work.
You manipulate the most
vulnerable people the easiest.
And of course, the
most vulnerable people
are the most problematic heroin
and crack cocaine users--
and also the most
vulnerable people, they've
got all the contacts, as
well, because they're using
more drugs than anybody else.
So I got to know the people
who were self medicating
for childhood trauma.
I spent time speaking to them.
People who had been abused,
beaten by their fathers,
sexually abused by their
uncles, or neglected
in one way or another.
The people who are
problematically using heroin
tend to have those kind
of things in common.
So I spent a lot of
time listening to them.
One of these people who had
a very difficult childhood I
got to know in an undercover
operation in Nottingham.
He was called [? Cammie. ?]
Now, I spent weeks wooing him.
I even brought him presents.
I set, oh, [? Cammie, ?]
I've been shoplifting.
I said, I didn't sell this
last cap, I said to him.
Shoplifting is great
fun, by the way.
If you can-- if you've got--
you'd get out of jail free card
and you can get away
with it, it really is.
It's great fun.
But I digress.
Anyway, so I gave him
this baseball cap.
And I'll never forget the
day he took his old one off,
his tatty cap off, and
he put his new one on
and checking out his profile
in the glass doorway.
He says, oh, thanks, man.
That's really great.
Thank you.
Anyway, I spent a lot of
time with [? Cammie. ?]
And he introduced
me to the people
I needed to be introduced
to, particularly
some people who were involved
with this gangster called
Colin Gunn who ran the
Bestwood cartel in Nottingham.
So he was the person who
got me to the introductions.
Now, at the conclusion of
that operation, of course,
[? Cammie ?] had also
been committing offenses.
In fact, he was committing
offenses on bail.
He'd been dealing
heroin himself.
So he also got arrested.
And I found out,
when all the people--
60-odd people arrested
for that operation.
And I found out that when
he was in the police cells
he ended up on minute-to-minute
watch, suicide watch.
And the reason for
that is he thought
I was his one friend in the
world, the only person he
could trust with the things
that he was talking about.
And of course, you know, I used
my empathy to get to know him.
I knew exactly what I was doing.
But for him, for someone who'd
had that difficult a childhood,
that was just one
betrayal too much.
So when I finished
the operation,
I actually decided I had
to stop working undercover.
And I did, for a few weeks,
until I got a phone call
from the detective sergeant.
And he says, Woodsy, we
need you to do this job,
because these guys are even
more vicious than the last ones.
This gang, the Burger
Bar Boys, are using rape
as reputation building, just
to be the scariest gangsters
out there.
And they were taking over the
supply of heroin and crack
in the town of Northampton.
They were a gang that was
coming out of Birmingham.
So I spent months, again,
manipulating people
in Northampton to get the
introductions to them.
And they were a terrifying
bunch, the Burger Bar Boys.
In fact, one day--
I had been wearing a camera,
because eventually you
have to have some
kind of corroboration
of what's going on.
I had been wearing one,
but one day I thought,
I don't like the way
they're looking at me.
They're being a bit
suspicious of me.
So the next morning, I thought,
shall I wear the camera?
And I didn't.
I left it off.
And wow, I was pleased that I
did, because when I met them,
they snatched me off the
street into this big van,
took me to the edge
of the racecourse
in the center of Northampton.
And one of them lifted his
shirt up and showed me a gun,
and said, right, come on, strip.
You're 5-0, man.
You're 5-0.
And yeah, they do.
They use the word 5-0.
I remember looking
at them thinking,
you're not old enough to
have seen that program on TV.
5-0?
Anyway, they made
me strip, which
was a terrifying experience,
especially with a gun there
and they're crowded
around me laughing at me
and trying to humiliate me.
And it was humiliating.
But I was still thinking, thank
God I didn't wear the camera.
But with all the horrors
that they were doing
and the casual violence
that they dished out,
eventually it dawned on me.
You see, when I'd
been manipulating
[? Cammie ?] and other
people and causing harm
to those people, I knew
I'd caused the harm.
I knew.
I knew that their lives would
be much worse for meeting me.
But I thought the end
justified the means.
But eventually, after years
and years of doing that work,
it dawned on me
that these gangsters
were getting more and
more violent every year.
They weren't wishing
me luck and telling me
not to get myself arrested.
They were threatening me with
guns and knives and swords.
And eventually, I had
the penny dropped and I
had to face the fact that the
reason for that is down to me,
or rather, people like
me, because this drug war,
if it's a war, it's
more of an arms race.
Because every tactic
the police develop,
organized crime develop
a tactic to deal with it.
And the best tactic
organized crime have is
the use of fear and violence.
So it's a cause
and effect, again.
It's like we've gone
from a few hundred heroin
addicts to 350,000.
There's a cause and effect.
By trying to police this
problem, that's what we do.
We cause the violence
as the pushback.
So that was hard for me,
because all those times I took
the decision that the end
justified the means, it didn't.
It didn't at all.
All I've been doing
is causing harm.
But I think that
perhaps would you
explain a bit better about
how the arms race work?
JS RAFAELI: Yeah.
Well, I can put it
in context, I guess.
So that process of an
arms race that Neil
saw where the police get smarter
so the gangsters get more
violent, so the police
have to get smarter,
and the gangsters have
to get more violent,
it's an ever-escalating
arms race.
And because of the
particular nature
of drug addiction
and the drugs market,
there's never any
option of de-escalation.
It can only go one way because
of the structure of policy.
Neil experienced
that very-- like,
in a brutal sort of
firsthand way on the street.
When we were researching
this book, essentially what
we were trying to
do, we realized,
was to show the war on drugs
not as a sort of process
of like headline by
headline by headline
sort of daily
hysteria over drugs,
but as a process of [? chits ?]
or change over time,
and to see how, actually,
over decades this has changed
and it's grown and
sort of metastasized
into the crisis we see today.
And we also-- we hung out
with quite a few pretty heavy
gangsters, interviewing
them, because they
have an important view on this,
the people who sell the drugs.
And we were up in
Liverpool, which
occupies a very specific
place in the sort of drugs
map of the UK, for various
historical reasons.
And we ended up interviewing
three generations
of Liverpool gangsters.
The first one came up in
the late '70s, early '80s.
I think he was first
arrested at 14 for robbery.
Got into very serious
armed robbery.
This was a scary guy.
Neil, as a cop, and
me as a journalist
have both interviewed
some pretty heavy people
in our careers.
And both of us came out of
this interview going, whew.
That guy is serious,
serious news.
A big guy.
He'd been shot four times
or-- three or four times.
I forget.
He had hands-- you could see
the damage from his hands
from where he had
damaged other people.
And he described how he had
come up in the armed robbery
world of the '80s and seen
the process by which the drugs
crisis, as it
emerged in the '80s,
wiped out the armed robbers--
or at least co-opted
the armed robbers.
And everyone became
a drug dealer
because there was just simply--
the risk to reward that you
can make from dealing drugs
far outweighs the
risk to reward you
can make from having to actually
take a gun, go to a bank,
you might get shot
by the police.
And the amount of
money you might
make in one armed robbery you
can make week in and week out
selling heroin to vulnerable
addicts without incurring
the kind of risk that
armed robbers do have.
Now, interestingly,
armed robbery actually
sort of went up when the drugs
crisis emerged because everyone
was trying to--
all the criminal
world were trying
to do an armed robbery in
order to get the capital
to invest in selling heroin.
So it's just bad
from all angles.
But what's interesting, as
much as this guy used guns,
he also talked about fighting
a lot-- like, actual,
physical fist fighting--
to solve turf wars and stuff.
The next guy was a slightly less
physically imposing, but just
as worrying a guy.
He'd been a very serious
gangster in the '90s.
He'd come up with the
ecstasy generation,
the early rave scene, made
a lot of money in that,
and then diversified his
portfolio into cocaine, heroin,
and guns.
And it was very interesting.
What he described
was a process of sort
of professionalization of this.
As opposed to the sort of
chaotic '70s and '80s world,
he was like, no,
no, what we did is
we read the biographies of
terrorists and figured out
how to divide our organization
into cellular structures
so that if one guy got
caught he wouldn't be
able to rat on the other guys.
And was this very
interesting process
of almost like corporatization,
professionalization.
And the money was phenomenal.
They came up.
But he also said
like, yeah, and if we
had a problem with the guy,
we took him to the event,
stuck a gun in his mouth, and
told him not to come back.
Or told him to stop
what he was doing.
And that was our thing, but I
don't think this guy had ever--
I know he'd never
been shot and I
don't think he'd ever
actually shot anybody.
But he the threat--
and people he knew
had certainly shot other people.
The third person we spoke
to was 16 years old.
And he'd been dealing
drugs since he was 13
and carrying a knife
since he was 13.
He had stopped dealing drugs,
he said, about six months
before we sat down and talked.
But he had-- yeah,
he had grown up
in a world where
that was normal.
And he described a--
sort of the chaos of the
currency, the monop-- sorry.
The monopolization,
which I described before,
from the '90s heavy
gangster, had been sort of
smashed up a bit by the police.
They'd had certain successes.
And what that had led to
is a sort of fragmentation
of the drug world, where the
guys at the very top are still
corporate and monopolized,
but the people at the low end,
this 16-year-old kid, there's
a chaotic element to it,
which suits--
it makes it harder for the
police to work to catch.
This kid described one
situation where he had--
at 15 years old, he'd had
a beef with another couple
of 15-year-olds.
They'd come looking for him.
They hadn't been
able to find him,
so they kicked in
the door of his house
and slashed his father
across the face with a knife.
15.
This kid, Alex-- the kid,
15-year-old we were talking
to--
he went to the boss--
his immediate boss in his
drug dealing organization
who is in his mid-20s and
said, look, these kids
have slashed my father
across the face.
I need a gun.
His boss said, you know what?
I've just sold my last gun.
I've got a hand grenade.
So this 15-year-old kid sat with
the hand grenade in his sock
drawer for six months waiting,
trying to find the other kids.
He wasn't able to find
them because they were off
doing something called
county lines, which
Neil is about to describe.
So he eventually sold
the hand grenade off.
What's interesting about this
is what we describe in the book
is it's a process of
three generations,
that the British drug war is
now in its third generation.
You have the generation
where drugs sort of came up,
where the armed robbers
became drug dealers.
You have the generation
of monopolization
and corporatization,
when the money flooded in
and the drug gangs
became organized and made
a lot of money.
And now you have
this third generation
of kids on the street who
have only been socialized
in the norms of the drug war.
And for them, these are
kids like this 16-year-old
who we interviewed.
This is normal.
This is what it is.
It's a process that
gets worse over time.
The arms race that
Neil describes
experiencing personally,
this is how it plays out
over a process of decades.
And what's interesting
is these two
hard gangsters, the guy who'd
been shot three times and the--
Mr. Gun In The Mouth--
they looked at the
14, 15-year-olds who
they knew on the street
now and were like, whoa.
I mean, we did some stuff, but
these kids now, they're crazy.
They're just-- and they looked
on with horror and fear,
like real fear, about what
the process, the arms race
had produced.
We asked the kid,
the 16-year-old,
how long would it
take for you right now
to get us a gun
if we wanted one?
Said about two hours, maybe an
afternoon, a whole afternoon
maybe.
We asked the older
guy, the '70s guy,
who had literally been shot
several times, how would
you have gone about
getting a gun in your day?
He said, well, what
I would have had
to have done is go to one
of the older gangsters, one
of the older heads, and been
like, look, I've got a beef.
I need a gun.
And they would have said,
you're not having a gun.
If you shoot somebody,
you'll have--
you'll bring the heat on us.
You'll bring the
cops down on us.
If you have a
problem with the guy,
go knock the hell out of each
other a bit and sort it out.
But don't bring the
police involved.
Don't get the police involved.
And the way that the older
gangsters talked about the kids
today, it was actually genuinely
terrifying, genuinely chilling.
And for a window into this sort
of emerging dystopia of what
the future holds if we proceed
with the same policies,
I'll let Neil jump in.
NEIL WOODS: OK.
So we talked about county lines.
Has everyone heard of
county lines drug dealing?
So in the UK, county
lines drug dealing
is the children being involved
in the supply of heroin
and crack.
It's primarily those two drugs,
but there's some other drugs,
as well.
And it's basically about--
it's about expanding monopolies
and the city gangs wanting
to take over the
businesses of other towns.
So if anyone's watching
this from America,
it's about the United
Kingdom finally catching up
with the amount of
children exploited
in America for drug
dealing, because it's
a sort of inevitability.
I say it's inevitable,
though, but actually
when I look at county
lines and what's happening,
that's my fault, because when
I caught the Burger Bar Boys,
they were adults who were taking
over the drug supply in one
town from the larger city.
But they were doing
it themselves.
They were hands on.
They were doing the dealing.
They were carrying the money.
They were stashing the money and
transporting it all themselves.
But successes like mine
and other police successes
have meant that the
natural strategic response
to that police success is
to start using children.
And that's what's happened.
It's a logical step.
This is what success looks like.
You see, police are
really, really good
at catching drug dealers.
They're brilliant at it.
Across the world they are.
If you give UK police
twice the resources
they can catch twice
the drug dealers.
It's true.
But police never reduce
the size of the market.
Never.
You catch a burglar,
burglaries will go down,
because there's a
limited amount of people
willing to commit that crime.
If you catch a drug dealer,
you create an opportunity
for somebody else.
And often, you
create the violence,
because then there's competition
for that opportunity.
And there's nothing that
police can do about that.
So the harder you try,
the worse things get.
So the youth, the children
dealing in county lines,
that's caused by
trying to police drugs.
So we now have--
we've gone-- we've talked
about the British System
and heroin being controlled
by the prescription pad.
It's now being controlled
by, as we've heard,
15-year-olds with hand grenades.
This is the reality
on the streets.
And it can only go
in one direction.
But there's something else I
need to explain to you all.
Again, for the British
audience, has everyone
been watching "Line of Duty"
or do you know about it?
Yeah.
Well, for Americans, it's
a cop show which exposes--
it's a drama which exposes
corruption, which some people
think is far fetched.
Well, let me tell you, it's
not necessarily far fetched.
Certainly not the corruption.
If I go back to [? Cammie's ?]
story in Nottingham,
the person he introduced me to
was a rather vicious guy called
[? Stets. ?] He interrogated
me with a knife pressed
into my groin.
It was a terrifying experience.
But he got me closer to the
gangster that I wanted to get.
I didn't actually get
the gangster I wanted.
That took another operation.
But a few months
later, Colin Gunn
was caught, the head of the
Bestwood Cartel in Northampton.
A brilliant operation by
Nottinghamshire police.
But at the time that I was
introduced to that guy,
[? Stets, ?] two of my
backup team went off sick.
And so two new
police officers were
brought in that I didn't know.
The first one of those,
I shook his hand.
It was fine.
The second one,
I shook his hand,
and the hairs went up
at the back of my neck.
Instinctively, everything
about this guy screamed wrong.
Now, when you've been working--
at that point, I'd been working
that job for 4 and 1/2 months.
When you're working
undercover, your senses
tend to be fairly fine tuned.
And I was picking up on just
some nuance of body language
that made me very unhappy.
So I spoke to the guy running
the operation, and said, boss,
I cannot have this guy
knowing what I'm doing.
I do not trust him.
So they were both excluded to
save them asking any questions,
and they didn't know
what I did that day.
It turns out, when
Colin Gunn was arrested
that this police officer, a
guy called Charlie Fletcher,
was an employee of Colin Gunn.
Not just a corrupt cop, he'd
been paid to join the police--
paid to join the police.
By the time I met him, he'd been
in the police for seven years.
He was paid 10,000
pounds a month
on top of his police wages, plus
bonuses for good information.
I was quite shocked.
Even though I'd come across
corruption many times,
it was still unsettling.
But senior police said to me,
Woodsy, of course this happens.
We know this happens.
With this much money involved,
how can it not happen?
See, I say that police are
good at catching dealers.
They are.
But by arresting lots
of dealers, what you do
is you thin out the competition
and help the monopolization.
So the gangsters who are
at the top of the tree,
they love the police
taking out the competition
because their part
of the empire grows.
And where you concentrate
the wealth into fewer hands,
you make corruption more
possible because there's
greater wealth to do it.
And let me make something
perfectly clear.
The only form of
criminality that
can pay for that
level of corruption
is the illicit drugs market.
There's no other
form of criminality
that can corrupt our
police and criminal justice
system like that.
10 billion pounds a year--
the value of the UK
illicit drugs market.
That's a lot of money that
can corrupt the system.
But it is the mechanism
of policing it
that creates the monopolies
that allows that corruption
to happen.
In the book--
I mean, I've come across
corruption many times--
but in the book, we interviewed
someone called Frank Matthews
who used to be a
supervisor of people
who went into the witness
protection system.
So the witness protection
system is in itself
a creation of the drug war.
Because until we
had the drug war,
witnesses were not too
scared to give evidence.
But such are the stakes
and the value in the market
that the whole system
is being corrupted.
So if someone wants
to give out evidence
against the leading
gangster in a city,
that gangster has all
the tools that they
need to try and intimidate
that witness to prevent them
from giving evidence.
So the witness protection
system is born.
So if someone, perhaps
to avoid a chunk of jail
sentence themselves, is
willing to give evidence
against an organized
crime group,
they are given a new identity.
They're never allowed to see
their family again or friends.
They go to the other
end of the country.
They're given a new
name and everything.
So there are people who
don't exist out there.
But what shocked us is what
Frank Matthews was able to tell
us-- 'cause he used
to work within that--
is that even that last defense
against organized crime--
the witness protection system--
even that is corrupted.
We were able to show
that with evidence
from Frank Matthews in the book.
He was a whistle-blower for
the Metropolitan Police.
Frank is not his real name.
He had to have a false
identity himself.
And you know, Frank spent a
career fighting the highest
echelons of organized crime.
But the first time he felt that
his life was truly in danger
was when he was crossing
up corrupt cops.
That's when he assumed
there was a hit on his life,
when he was most at risk.
So I think--
I hope we've established
the cause and effect here.
And I hope we've
established what direction
this is going in.
As each generation goes
on, for every year, decade
that this drug war is
entrenched in our policy,
it's only going
in one direction.
And if you look
around the world,
the monopolization effect
doesn't just happen in the UK.
It happens in other
countries as well.
Look at how Mexico--
the cartels go to
war with each other,
and then eventually,
someone has dominance,
and the monopoly takes over.
The biggest violence
increases are
when someone's actually caught,
like anywhere in the world.
But in Mexico,
the detection rate
of murders, the rate
where a murder is solved
is less than 1%.
And that's because you're
as likely to be killed
by one of the police
officers as you
are anybody else, because they
tend to work for the cartels.
The corruption is
spreading across the world.
You now have narco states
in West Africa just where
the production, the
transport of drugs happens,
because they have low economies,
and they are easily corrupted.
This corruption is spreading,
and it is inevitable
until we take control of
drugs by regulating them.
So I'm part of an organization,
an international organization
called the Law Enforcement
Action Partnership.
It started in the
United States, which
I think is fair enough because
they lumbered us with this drug
war in the first place.
In America, we have
prosecutors, chiefs
of police, lots of former
senior police officers.
In the UK, we have former
chief constables, former MI5,
lots of other former
undercover cops like me.
And we're growing rapidly.
We've just registered
LEAP Europe and Paris.
Last year we launched
LEAP Scandinavia.
And thank you for the
introduction earlier on, Chris.
We slightly changed our name
since you introduced us.
We used to be
against prohibition.
We still are but, we
just have a better name.
So we're the Law Enforcement
Action Partnership.
So anyone watching from
America, please support
LEAP as much as you can.
And in UK, it's much the same.
So I'm going to see now from
JS if I've missed anything,
or to sum up for us?
JS RAFAELI: No, I think
let's open up for questions.
NEIL WOODS: Yeah.
JS RAFAELI: We'll have a chat.
AUDIENCE: Does the political
influence from the US
that you mentioned that
started this whole demise
of the British System
after World War II,
does that still exist today?
Or is our drug policy
still influenced
by what the US wants?
JS RAFAELI: [INAUDIBLE].
NEIL WOODS: Yeah,
well the US influence
reached its pinnacle and a
fairly indelible pinnacle
in 1961 with a treaty--
the United Nations
Conventions on Narcotic Drugs.
And that was a
treaty that everyone
had to sign up to, really.
They'd spent a couple of
decades winning everybody around
to do that.
And it's interesting that that
single treaty in the United
Nations, which forces everyone
to follow the prohibition model
according to the
United States doctrine,
how it's described in
the United Nations.
Drugs are described as evil.
It's the only United Nations
treaty which uses that word.
Genocide, they don't
use the word evil.
So genocide's not
evil, but drugs are.
So you can see that even in
the writing of the treaty
that sort of moral judgment
is written into it.
So each individual nation
state is actually quite limited
according to international
law in how they
shape their own drug policy.
It actually restricts
innovation now.
But that's starting
to break down.
Because in 2001, Portugal--
which the United
Nations said at the time
they were breaching the treaty--
Portugal decriminalized drugs.
It's not a perfect system
because organized crime still
controls the supply,
so they still
have the same level
of corruption.
But people don't go to
jail for using drugs.
And whereas, they used to
have more deaths than us.
Now, whereas, we have
50 deaths per million,
they now have three
deaths per million.
So you can see that a
health-based approach helps.
But there are, of
course, bigger breaches
of that treaty by the
United States themselves.
They have several states
which legally regulated
cannabis for adult use.
So they've broken the treaty.
Which really, so it's
the United States which
has opened the floodgates.
That means everything's
on the table.
The rules have
already been broken.
Canada has just legally
regulated cannabis
for adult use right
across the whole country.
So they've gone even farther
than the United States.
Obviously, Uruguay
does the same.
Switzerland prescribes
heroin like we used to do.
And as a result, they've
cut burglaries in half
and saved countless lives.
So there are examples of good
drug policy which is coming--
now, it's almost
like we're starting
to cast off those shackles
of the United Nations
single convention in 1961.
AUDIENCE: There's an argument
that the privatization
of the prison
systems across the US
has actually resulted in
higher levels of incarceration.
Is that a similar
system, you think,
is now playing out in the UK
as we adopt a similar model?
Do you think that's actually
one of the driving forces
behind the laws not changing?
JS RAFAELI: Neil, I
think you should-- yeah.
NEIL WOODS: Yeah.
There's a different type of
corruption in America as well.
And that is like--
so corporate corruption.
And the influence of
both the financing
behind private prisons and also,
actually, the prison officers
unions put great
pressure on politicians
to not change the drug laws.
And the reason for that
is America has only 5%
of the world's population.
They have almost a quarter of
the world's prison population.
One in three black
families have a male adult,
a male parent in prison.
I mean, this is
absolutely extraordinary.
From the redeclaration of
the war on drugs from Reagan,
at that time they had around
200,000 people in prison.
Now they have 2.2 million.
That's an incredible
increase, and it's
all about the war on drugs.
And it's made things worse,
because they have the highest
opioid problem in the world.
They have the
biggest drug deaths.
It's causing carnage.
You know, there is another
cause and effect there.
So to answer your
question, there
is a huge political influence
in lobbying in the USA,
and it is one of the
many stumbling blocks
to reform in the United States.
But as to the
question in the UK.
No, we don't have that excuse.
I think our private
prisons have actually
reduced in the last few years.
There was one closed.
I think there's only
seven, actually.
And, of course, the way that
the system works in the United
Kingdom, there
are limits to what
financial lobbying can be done.
So you're not going to have
quite the same influence
on politicians--
financial influence.
So we don't have the
same excuse, really.
Our politicians
don't, I would say.
JS RAFAELI: So can
I just jump in?
There is a absolute
indelible connection
between the war on drugs and not
the prison industrial complex
that they have in the States.
But there is a massive crisis
in UK prisons right now.
And it's worth remembering that
over 50% of prisoners in the UK
are there for
drug-related offenses.
So you get occasional
commentators across the media--
I will not mention names, but--
who say, well, the war
on drugs has never really
been fought in the UK.
It's an absurdity, because over
50% of the prison population
is there, yeah, for
drug-related offenses.
There was a report
just the other day--
I mean, just two days ago about
a new unit, a special unit that
has been formed to combat
police officers sneaking drugs
into prisons.
There's a drug crisis
inside prisons.
We can't keep drugs
out of prisons.
How are we going to keep
them out of society?
If you come from the reading
that Neil and I have done,
you, say, oh, there's a new
unit to combat corruption
among prison guards.
I give it three weeks before
that unit is corrupted, too.
So then that is the,
like you said, is--
unique to drugs
prohibition policing
is that creating
a market which can
corrupt the institutions
which are meant
to combat it on that level.
And it's absolutely unique
to the war on drugs.
AUDIENCE: Given America
obviously tried prohibition
with alcohol, and it
failed pretty badly,
do you have any insight
into why, therefore, there
was such a drive to try not only
prohibition within the States
but outside of the
States with drugs?
Because it seems that
it's an odd lesson
to take from how they tried
prohibition with alcohol.
JS RAFAELI: Interesting.
The prohibition
of drugs precedes
prohibition of alcohol.
So the Harrison
Narcotics Tax Act
was 1914, which
is what made drugs
we now consider illegal illegal
inside the United States.
Interestingly-- this
is my geeky historian--
the first American
prohibition regime
wasn't instituted in
the United States.
It was instituted
in the Philippines
after the Spanish-American
War when America
took over the
Philippines, and it
was an extension of that racist
impulse and discourse in the US
that, ah, well, there are
Asian people doing these drugs.
We have to clamp down on it.
So it was sort of when we
describe the war on drugs
as a process of
American imperialism,
cultural imperialism, and
just imperialist imperialism,
it's actually, if you look
at the history of this
and how it grew,
it's quite literal.
It was literally a
process of when America
became an imperial
power and had colonies
beyond its own borders, it
instituted drug prohibition
regimes then.
What the campaigners
within the United States,
they tried to institute
it on the world stage,
internationally before they
banned drugs in America.
And, of course, the
rest of the world
went, well, we're
not banning drugs.
You don't even ban
drugs inside America.
And it was mainly the
British saying that.
And so the Americans
went, oh, right.
Well, we better prohibit
drugs in America
so that we can then export
it to the rest of world.
And that's the process
by which it happened.
So, yeah, no lessons
were learned.
NEIL WOODS: Yeah, absolutely.
And another lesson
which, of course,
should have been learned
from alcohol prohibition
is that actually, there
are various reasons why
it came to an end.
But the most important
reason is the public realized
just how much it was
corrupting the police.
So you hear that Eliot
Ness and The Untouchables.
The reason that he was
called The Untouchables
because the press mocked him.
Because he did an
interview and said,
well, my team are untouchable.
So the press had their full
front pages the next day
saying, finally, we found some
cops which are untouchable.
So that there's only 12 of them.
And that's how he
got the nickname.
And it was that knowledge
of the corruption, what
it was doing to the system
which actually turned
public opinion against it.
Which is why it's so
important to realize
just the level of corruption.
And, of course, it's
really difficult
to highlight the corruption
because the Home Office
instructs chief constables to
maintain public confidence.
Of course, that's important.
If you lose confidence
in the police then
the fabric of society could
break down, et cetera.
Well, I've got news
for you, Home Office.
The fabric of society
is breaking down,
and people are losing confidence
because we're not being honest,
and we're not actually dealing
with the problems that exist.
So yeah, please,
please, wish more people
and studied what happened
in the 1920s in America.
AUDIENCE: If you had
a magic wand, what
would be your first
policy, and what
do you think would have
the biggest impact?
NEIL WOODS: Oh,
well, that's easy.
And it's easy for all reasons
because it's already legal.
The policy's already there.
I wouldn't have to change
any law whatsoever.
You prescribe heroin liberally
to those people that need it.
So you go back to
the British System.
You do that, overnight, 80%
of the market for county lines
drug dealing by
children exploited
would disappear completely,
because that's mostly
about heroin.
The crime, the hard
core of those people
who are having a problem
with heroin commit,
disappears overnight.
Shoplifting stops.
It sounds easy.
Well it is.
It's in our history.
It's there.
OK, OK, it's a bigger
scale problem now.
We're talking
200,000-plus people.
But if you've got to start
taking care of people,
not everybody would need to
keep on a heroin prescription.
Many people would have
found the stability
in their life to move on to
then another kind of treatment.
But if you invest
in the treatment,
even a fraction of what is spent
on law enforcement, a fraction,
you would tackle the problem
that law enforcement cannot do.
And taking care of people's
cheaper than treating them
as criminals, significantly.
So that's the
first thing I'd do.
Then you can start breaking
all the other drugs
into the individual regulatory
needs that those drugs have,
because they do have
different regulatory needs.
Cannabis, you have to decide
what strength product, what
type of product can be
sold to whom and where,
and where can it be used?
It's much like alcohol, really.
But we can do better than we
did with alcohol because we can
ban advertising straight away.
We can take out those kind
of commercial elements
and base it on a
health-based approach.
For MDMA, for
example, MDMA is not
prohibited because
it's dangerous.
It's dangerous because
it is prohibited.
People are dying because
that's a unregulated product.
You pick any death
over the last few years
and look at what's caused it.
It's been caused because it
wasn't MDMA that they bought
or it's four times too strong.
Regulation will save
lives and reduce harm.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, what's MDMA?
NEIL WOODS: MDMA's ecstasy.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
NEIL WOODS: You know,
in British summer,
there might be a million people
dancing in a field on MDMA.
Are they deviant,
or do they just
like to dance in a
field with the help
of a certain stimulant?
And if you agree
with me, then you're
part of the social movement.
And please, start passing
on this information
to other people, because
that's how we win.
We speak to a lot of politicians
between us a great deal.
And it's good to try to
influence politicians.
You're more important,
because you're
part of a social movement.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so given the
relaxation of the US policy
with regards to
marijuana, what do
you see as the biggest obstacle
internally to changes that you
described in UK drug policy?
NEIL WOODS: The biggest
obstacles in the UK.
Oh there's a few.
JS RAFAELI: It's a really
interesting, complex question,
because it's really
multifaceted, isn't it?
I mean, inertia would
be a massive one.
NEIL WOODS: Is there a argument
that actually journalism
is the biggest--
JS RAFAELI: Well, I
was going to say that.
But, yeah, yeah, my profession
are a massive problem.
[LAUGHTER]
Massive problem.
I read out some quotes
before of these racist quotes
from the early 20th
century in the US.
And everyone in the
room just winced.
[GASPS] And I've done
these events before,
and I've done much
further, and I've read out
quote after quote after quote.
And there's this cringe that
people, go, uh, people actually
wrote that.
Uh.
Addressing my
profession, the members
of the media, journalists
and editors who
are writing today right now.
In 25 years, maybe
sooner, maybe 10 years,
we will look back on how drug
users are described today
with the same cringe
that we, today, look back
at the racist language used
to describe drug users,
and people who didn't use
drugs, just ethnic minorities,
in the early 20th century.
And I warn journalists, and
I warn editors of that a lot.
When people talk
about spice zombies
it's the dehumanization
of people
who use drugs in the media,
especially the tabloid media.
It's a huge toxic problem.
And the tabloid media
has a particular--
because of the media
landscape in the UK--
it's particularly strong.
It has a particular weight here.
And politicians are particularly
scared of crossing it.
Politicians are trailing
public opinion at this point.
But the media has a
huge toxic role in it.
AUDIENCE: Do you think that
organized crime is successfully
lobbying through corruption
to resist reform?
Like, are they, you know,
corrupting or pouring money
into resisting this
societal change?
NEIL WOODS: I would
say that's inevitable
because at the very highest
echelons of organized crime
and international cartels there
is a very thin and blurry line
between genuine business and
the money for the drugs markets,
because the drugs markets'
money makes the world go round.
You only have to look
at the scandal with HSBC
a few years ago.
They were seen to be laundering
huge amounts of money
from the illicit drugs market.
And no one was prosecuted.
It wasn't even
seriously considered.
So there is an obvious
interconnection
where money meets money
at the top of the pyramid.
But what I would say
is as we move forward.
And we will move forward because
there is lots of innovations
happening across the world.
That influence will
become stronger
because where big
business of any kind
finds itself threatened, whether
it's the oil lobby in America,
paying politicians, the same
kind of thing will happen.
And it will be very difficult
to spot, I would say.
JS RAFAELI: Yeah, I mean,
I've spoken to drug dealers.
And I've explained
my position on it.
And they say, expletive,
expletive, expletive, you're
going to do me out of a job.
The drug dealers on a big
scale, high-level gangsters,
are far more scared
of the reform movement
than they are of the cops.
NEIL WOODS: Mm, absolutely.
JS RAFAELI: We will
do much more damage
to murderous, bloody
cartels across Latin America
than the police there will.
NEIL WOODS: Mm.
JS RAFAELI: It's much
more of a threat.
NEIL WOODS: Yeah.
JS RAFAELI: Because
we're not pro-cartel.
They do bad things.
They're awful.
The threat to them is
through a regulated model,
not through continuing
a failed system which
is going to create even
more dystopian outcomes 20
years down the line.
SPEAKER: Thank you so
much for coming in.
JS RAFAELI: Thank you.
Thanks, thanks.
[APPLAUSE]